first of all i
i don't know yesterday was just
absolutely uh
out of control but i'm going to give you
my perspective and it's going to be
long-winded so
go for it i'm going to go for a few
minutes and share with you where i'm at
so
okay so you know election happens uh uh
coronavirus okay some can speculate and
say that was used to politicize and shut
us down and yesterday i interviewed a
guy named uh
john m uh john barry
great conversation 90 minutes he's the
guy that wrote the book the great
influenza of 1918 and 2004
and it became a top seller his first
book i think he's got stuff in the
library congress he's a very
legendary writer for washington post new
york he's written for everybody pretty
much right and he was there
in the 90s he's a guy that was born in
1947 so he's been around politics for a
long time
while we're doing the interview was at
the peak like that's when the girl got
shot while we're doing the interview
right
and he says all this stuff you know well
let me tell you trump this trump then
he's full-on
democratic calls out trump the entire
time while we're doing the interview
and in my mind you know here's how i
process this
okay um both
sides use the same strategy and tactic
okay both sides the left protests
riots but the media said it's peaceful
protesting
so you have to know to me it goes to the
number one cause of this flare
i'm looking at who instinct instigated
this the most that's where i go to
number one
is the number one instigator obama um
no although obama under his reign every
time you said anything you're racist
so that's something that came back a lot
under obama we didn't have that with a
lot with others but he came up under
obama
any time anybody said anything about
obama they said well because he's black
right
you're being racist about it okay fine
is it obama's fault was obama a guy that
was divisive
maybe a little bit because he's a
community organizer but at this level
absolutely not so then you continue and
then you say okay is it trump's fault
um of course everything rises and falls
on the leader which is trump
but at the same time trump's a fighter
so trump's somebody that's been fighting
like this his entire career it's nothing
new what trump's doing right
to me everything falls
on the media everything to me falls on
the media
the media told a different story on one
side and told a different story on the
other side so you got
you got yesterday a veteran who was in
the air force i believe 14 years she did
four tours
who's standing there she gets shot falls
the guy grabs her he doesn't know what's
going on he sees blood in his hands and
later on two hours later she ends up
dying
they have a business in san diego she
lives in san diego she's a pro-trump
supporter comes out
think about the people that came out to
support that thing they're doing the
right thing and they're walking into
capitol hill
you know and others are saying well this
was all antifa it wasn't pro-trump
support it was antifa that was there
no no no this was trump supporters that
went into the capitol hill there's
nothing about it that's not the
uh uh that wasn't trump supporters
here's the other part you know how
people say
you know republicans don't play as dirty
as democrats do
okay you know you i don't know if you've
ever heard that saying before or not
yeah
republicans aren't willing to go to
places that democrats are willing to go
democrats will go and say community
organized protest
rally little bit of rights make some
noise ruckus it's okay oh they're angry
they're upset
do you blame them you should you would
be also upset if you were them right
but because whatever you say it's kind
of like uh
you you know i have a friend of mine who
a stepfather and a son
and a wife right so the wife his wife
has a son
but it's a stepson to him right so no
anytime he tries to discipline the son
this the mother says what
that you were too tough on him you don't
talk to him like that
and he's like dude i can't develop your
son i can't do anything i can't be a man
of the household because any time i try
to discipline your son
you'll always come in and protect what
the son so the sons of what a baby
and the son always goes to who mommy
okay
any time the rioters or protesters on
the left came out on the streets and
they were protesting
guess who the mommy was that said oh
they're just upset why are you so media
the media would say they're upset do you
blame them
but yesterday when republicans do it oh
why why are they doing this this is an
atrocity
the only difference on why yesterday was
an atrocity
is you do not go to the capitol hill
which represents your country the
constitution everything that was
eloquently written
years ago to give you freedom and you go
into that house
you don't do that in a family siblings
can fight all day long
you cross the line and you disrespect
the parents you just cross the line body
that's a problem
if siblings are republicans and
democrats they're fighting fine
the parents the forefathers that build
this country that's capitol hill that's
our history that's what we stand for
you guys crossed the line so now you're
going out there sometimes and you're
rallying right
let me tell you you know here's what
they're doing they stole they did this
and they did that
fine there's a part of me that believes
there was voter fraud there's a part of
me that believes it was voter fraud
because of uh
uh 100 why is it all of a sudden you
shut it down at 10 30. i'm sorry
oh we're gonna stay last night until we
vote in the electoral
la i don't care how long it takes really
how come you didn't have the same
mindset on voting night
why didn't you say i'm voting now we're
gonna stay until we figured out three
o'clock in the morning
hell or how we're going to stay here why
don't you have that same attitude on
that night what stage
georgia what time did pennsylvania shut
it down michigan how many states oh
we're not going to do it we're not going
to stay up why aren't you going to stay
up
why are you not going to stay up how
come you don't have i agree with you on
that welcome
all night my point how come you don't
have the same level of enthusiasm so
where is the skepticism
where does the skepticism come in my
step at what point does
losing every losses no no hang on a
second no but wait a minute
why did you shut it down at 10 30. there
is skepticism in there it's very fair to
be skeptical they answered those
questions yet
of course they don't have to answer the
questions what do you mean they should
who has to answer the questions
the lawmakers we're going to need to
cancel tomorrow what do we say about it
nothing media is not controlled by the
right
it's controlled by the left so they have
again the mommy says
oh they have to count or they have to
count oh it's so much pressure right now
for them
they're gonna probably need for two
months they were telling us they're
probably gonna need 30 days to figure
everything out no you didn't
why'd you need that additional 30 days
every single damn time you can figure
out one out until tonight
of course you're gonna piss off an
audience 75 million people are pissed
off
you're wondering why they're pissed off
why don't you stay up that night until
you figured it out
here's the other thing that pisses me
off about this whole thing uh
so i'm at the airport the other day tsa
says oh we don't need your uh this guy
is talking to me he's rolling his asses
which is totally fine so he's rolling
his esses and saying
sir uh i just have to tell you moving
forward you don't need to show your
you don't have to show your uh uh
boarding pass we don't need your
boarding pass all we need is id
because nowadays technology is advanced
and the id can't say a lot
and i said yeah we should do that for
voting as well well that's a different
story because when it comes down to that
you're racial i'm sorry
wait what's a different story if you
need my id to get on a damn flight
which is just a flight what's more
important
who the president is or a flight why
don't you use my id
to vote i guarantee you the results will
be different there is so much hypocrisy
today
in america now let me bring you back so
i just went
left right left right left someone's
pissed off on both sides with me right
now because of what i'm saying but this
will sound wired
bring you back to the way it was
yesterday okay
yes there was voter fraud 100 it was
voter fraud
even if it's low high it was voter fraud
at the levels
i don't know i believe there was simply
because of that night you didn't
count until the end of the end of the
night so there's nothing that anyone can
convince in your mind that that was not
from
bro let me tell you if everything was
just on the democrat side every
of course it's just on the democrats no
republicans because they
it was the cities that was was the
cities and states that was controlled by
the left of course it's on their side
right
historically if you're asking me i'm
going to say both sides but historically
voter fraud has always been on the left
not penalties
the only year that the republicans did
not have voter fraud no i'm not telling
you they don't do it either i tell you
they do but this year around
who do you think uh uh mail and ballot
helps more republicans or democrats
clearly democracy
tell me why though tell me why though
well tell me why they were promoting
million ballots but tell me why though
because there's a freaking pandemic and
i asked you a question yesterday i said
when you voted how did you vote male 1
banner but what's the big deal and i
said did you have to show your i didn't
print it and you said uh
uh uh no i don't think i stumbled yeah
but but you didn't have an answer for it
no i had a male 1
how did i know that was you i facetimed
nancy pelosi do you understand
but do you understand the hip then yeah
the stupidity of that yeah i don't trust
it
i don't trust that if you need my damn
id to get on a damn flight you need my
id to vote
i don't trust them but then you're
saying that no mail and ballot ballot
should ever exist no i don't
i i think you have to go in person and
vote yes i do no matter what i do
what because you want to act what about
early voting
what happens if you're accuracy
important to you of course is it
come show up come show up so one day
come show up why can't we vote for a
month
i don't care if we vote for six months
why does it have to be one day i don't
care if it's half the people can't get
off of work hear me out i don't care if
it's six months in india they take like
a month to vote did you hear what i just
said yeah
i don't care if it's six months i want
you to show up
i want you to show up and give your id
that's what i'm asking for i'm not
asking you for anything more than that
i'm not one day is stupid
how am i gonna take one day off would
you trust it if someone can
figure out some freaking technology and
we can vote from our phones no
you need to show your face that's it uh
bottom line you have to be there
dude how do you check into an airline an
airport well you have to physically be
there to get okay
great you want to physically vote
physically show up and vote i don't know
i do know i don't know now the other
side is this way if you're out of town
when times if you're military
you got six months and you're freaking
out you guys are in russia a month you
got you have to fly home to vote you go
no put it put a voting boot over there
and have somebody go and show up and say
here's who i am
why can't you take a copy of your idea
and like send in a copy because i can do
that for you and i can just take
ah do you think that's gonna be are you
really this naive though buddy yes i am
you are really this nice
honestly though you're really this nice
i'm just saying what are the rea there's
people that can't get ideas there's
people that can't afford ideas if you
can't go to the dmv they can't do all
that you're talking about
mail-in ballots higher chance of
manipulation
you are naive if you don't buy into that
left or right
period let's set that part aside and
let's go to the other side
trump trump's a sore loser period
yeah he he you know there's other ways
of losing i've lost
publicly and it sucks no one likes it
and for me i bet i bet with you telling
you where i was at voting why so it's
not like i'm sitting here telling you
you lost fear by the way i fully
understand his pain
i fully understand his agitation because
he's a guy that's accustomed to winning
but he became the pistons not the bulls
he became he became isaiah thomas
by doing this you don't do that you're
lost you disagree with certain calls
say it i didn't like the cause of
referees mate tonight fine say it
so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch or
if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody bye